[Music]
let's go to maggie who joins us in
chicago illinois maggie how can we help
hi guys thanks so much for taking my
call really glad it's you instead of
dave today because i have a credit card
question hold on a second hold on on a
sec i've never heard a caller say that
before this is fantastic
i want to i want to revel in this for
just one moment
okay that's enough dave are you
listening okay yeah yeah well okay so
here's my question we i know credit
cards are bad i totally get the
philosophy behind it i 100 get that but
all of our main
fixed bills come out the first half of
the month so when we get paid twice a
month
if we pay everything the way we're
supposed to we really don't have money
left
for our day-to-day stuff our groceries
the kids stuff that pops up all that
until
we get paid the second half of the month
so what ends up happening is we just
kind of put everything on the credit
card do our fixed bills out of the first
paycheck and then credit card and you
know a couple other things out of the
second paycheck so
it works but i know that i could be
saving more money if i wasn't pulling
out the plastic if i had cash for
everything i just can't come up with
enough cash to make that work does that
make sense
it does but this is just a budgeting
issue yeah and you need a little buffer
in the checking account and then we need
to start budgeting for those bills we
know when they're coming in and you can
actually call a lot of these companies
and set a certain date of the month when
you want to pay those bills i also
wonder uh maggie before you respond to
george on that is this also an income
issue
no i mean we're fine we're debt-free
we're working on paying off the house
early um i just think it's kind of set
up in a way and
i i mean i've just i've always done the
i do the bills so i've always just kind
of done the credit card and then just
paid that off instead of and i do take
cash out i should say that too um like
the first of the months when we get paid
that's going to be the mortgage and um
you know the insurance that we put aside
and um those kind of things and then i
do take out like
i take out cash for groceries i take out
cash for um you know some cash but i
feel like i always there's always
something that i'm putting on the credit
card anyway whether it's you know the
kids my kids are in sports so it's like
oh well you know we just lost my
football gloves at practice okay we
gotta run out to dicks and get more
batting or um you know football gloves
or you know there's always something
that i end up so it sounds like there's
things outside of the budget that catch
you off guard it's not bills because you
said there's certain things what i do is
i have yeah and i have a bunch of um
like syncing funds so then i will just
transfer like we have a kids account so
you know we put the money in the kids
account and if i if i have to buy those
gloves and i'll transfer money over but
i still i just feel like as
well as i think we're doing with money i
feel like i still have that problem
where if i didn't have
the credit card
as kind of a catch-all that we would be
you know stuck in you know certain times
of the month well it sounds like this
credit card has become a crutch and a
safety blanket yeah so i think if we cut
that bad boy up and we have a little bit
of buffer in our checking account and we
start to get this budget dialed in we
figure out when the bills are coming in
and we use our previous income to pay
for future expenses that would solve all
of these problems right
yeah so how does that work because
that's you know we kind of do the zero
my husband always wants to put a little
extra in the checking account for that
reason but then i feel like if there's
extra in there then we're gonna go
through it
when we should be at a zero base well
you need some check zero base doesn't
mean you have zero dollars in your
checking account it means that you've
assigned every dollar a job as far as
your income goes so you definitely need
to have a buffer in your checking
account maybe that's 500
maybe it's a thousand dollar buffer in
there uh but again that's on you of
self-discipline to go we're not gonna
touch it a thousand dollars is basically
zero
that is our that's our starting point
and i think that will help you alleviate
some of these uh credit card habits
to go spending and make sure junior
doesn't lose his glove
well you can't do that jordan i mean
come on yeah they're 13 year old boy i'm
i'm over it thank you she's done with
this guys
for the next five years i feel you're
paying back it's on him to pay for that
yeah well there you go george like she
can't control that he's you know he's
got a much better life lose one glove
shame on me lose two shame on you yeah
well maggie george has no kids okay he
doesn't understand the pain that you and
i are dealing with i understand personal
responsibility oh do you yeah
do you we'll see how you understand that
when your kid loses everything
uh anyways maggie i think this is this
is part budgeting issue and it's part a
scheduling issue figuring out when the
bills are coming in so if you know those
bills are catching you off guard let's
schedule them and say hey electric
company i want to pay on the 15th
instead of the fourth yeah and you can
settle
my husband got he we went from a first
and fifteenth to his company switched to
every other
week which has totally been throwing a
wrench in the works because to try and
you know we have our money that goes out
you know into savings at a certain time
every month and that's become
an issue because if he gets paid one day
later it's like oh now i got to go back
and change it well you guys are
debt-free so why not have one month full
of expenses ready to go in the checking
account that way you're not stressing
about if you're going to have enough and
so that can be a budgeting strategy that
helps a lot of folks to be a whole month
ahead so you're not wondering if you're
gonna have enough but again the better
strategy is to do a rock solid budget
use your previous income from that check
is going to pay the future expenses yeah
and i don't want the audience uh to miss
what george said
because it's really true it's a simple
little hack
most companies will work with you if you
just call them up and go hey i'm going
to put this on autopay they love that so
you've already got them at that point so
here's my debit card let's auto pay but
instead of hitting me on the fourth of
the month or the third i'd like you to
hit me on the 20th or the 18th if i
could pay you know they'll work with you
on that stacey and i've had to do that
multiple times because the way we get
paid here as well it's just kind of like
hey and it's fine they'll work with you
and that way you get things a little bit
more uniformed uh and laid out that way
so that's that's a great hack and a lot
of them let you do it on your own online
so look into that if not give them a
call yeah email them whatever you gotta
do i i you strike me as a guy who has
everything automatically 100
like you get you get a text all the time
going mr campbell you've just paid your
electric bill yes now it's twofold i put
it on autopay but i don't just let it go
and not know what my bills are so i get
the email yeah i put everything on
paperless because you know me i'm a
millennial i don't want i don't want a
paper what do i do with this paper i
know you really you really haven't
gotten to the first paper yeah not here
even the papers on the desk stresses me
out so i i get the email so i know what
the bill is so that i don't hear that
george oh i can't stand it that's the
best of the paper all of america wants
you to stop doing that i don't know i
think the people in the lobby are
laughing they like the sound of the
paper crinkling it's a win we gotta
mention
putting things on autopilot on autopay
doesn't mean we're not paying attention
i think that's right good so we have to
know hey what's your system the bill was
twice as much this month you don't want
that to sneak up so do you get an email
every time that's what i was saying you
get an email or text that's what i was
assuming you exactly so the electric
bill i get the email at the end of the
month saying hey here's what the bill is
going to be and i go cool that sounds
about right and it's on auto pay so i
don't have to think about it i don't
have to
get you know one of those late
collection bills in the mail not dealing
with that so i'm a big fan of auto pay
but you got to pay attention still yeah
yeah and i think when you hear that
phone call like that you know sometimes
people just feel like they they have to
play by everybody else's rules
and you know you don't have to because
companies want to get paid your your
system is broken and i talked with our
friend craig rochelle about this on the
entre leadership podcast recently
it's time for a new system yeah and that
means replacing the old broken system
and the old bad habits and replacing it
with good healthy habits and that might
mean having a buffer in the checking
account it may mean scheduling your
bills to hit on a certain day right and
it's those simple little things that
really give you confidence in the plan
and go oh i can do this thing i don't i
can cut up the cards i don't need them
they were a crutch they were a safety
blanket so if that's you america i agree
it's time for a new system well and the
theme here the is is underneath all of
this is that you can control certain
things take control of what you can
control and you can control your budget
you can control your planning you can
control the date by which you pay the
bills these are all things that you can
control
that's that's really the ramsay message
at its core i mean it is it really can
take control yeah you got this i'm
curious that when your electric bill
spikes is because of the uh incessant
hair drying if you have more than one
shower in a day it's about four minutes
a day ken yeah you know little things
about george that you find when you go
on a retreat with him he dries his hair
with a blow dryer before going to bed
hey this volume doesn't just happen on
its own ken yeah his room wasn't his
room kelly was next to mine he's
blow-drying he's here to let's not talk
about your snoring ken that's a whole
other topic